have you seen a Frozen ride yes it's
nasty it's crazy Frozen rats but mine's
fresh and it's [__] um it's it's cage
free yeah organic and it's local it's
New York raised local
[Music]
this was mentioned yesterday but we
pulled up a nice little article on it
today there is
a rat problem in New York City
who's talking let me see them
they're [__] big
[__] all these [__] rats right we
don't take no rats they just get
stitches yeah unfortunately we're
actually talking about rodents rodents
uh the actual rat which rodents let me
see
lioness I'll smash them
so literally New York is now looking and
seeking a Hands-On leader in the
anti-rodden fight which is uh being
dubbed the rat SAR if you haven't done
this this is like now they're starting
to do this wait rats are like a Russian
leader yeah like a Russian the official
job title is quote director of rodent
mitigation it was like a dub the rats
are and the salary range is anywhere
from 120 to 170 000. they should caught
on the [__] Master Splinter I would
take a smaller deal but like pay me per
rat I get rid of I would want a pretty
commission that might be 10 cents
because you're like there's about a
million rats in the city you know what I
would do then I would keep secretly
breeding the rats and then I keep
killing them but I can't use my cousin
with a different last name than me
breeding them Rat Factory yep that's the
Peter Piper what's gonna happen when
Peter gets a hold of this [__] and
they're like you are not killing no rats
it's a New York staple yeah do you think
Peter's allowed to get involved with
when it's like a um what's called like
[__] I don't think they care
no it's an animal and I think Peter
animals are more important than humans
have you ever seen that there was this
like episode of Hoarders or some [__]
where the dude kept like hundreds of
rats in his house as pets and then so
they had like an animal control people
come and get all the rats out of his
house and he straight up told him he
because he was like emotional he's like
no my rats they straight up said don't
worry we're not killing him we're just
gonna move them to a different home
[__]
hundreds of rats are gonna be adopted
come on and they really lied to him they
put him in an incinerator yeah they're
gonna [__] burden them that's too
many rats yeah I think there's there's
no humane way to get rid of rats yes
there is there's one way
at the reptile Farm is that where the
Mushroom King places too no you go to
the rep have you ever been to the
reptile store I've been a reptile zoo
someone uh some lady brought in a turtle
and they just took it like I just found
a turtle in a pond and brought it oh
let's take it in dude they think they'll
take because they're gonna feed that
[__] ball constrictor with the red
ear slider that's why so you think
they're gonna have room over a million
rats is that how many rats that are that
are that is the problem a million don't
they say there's more I don't even count
a million like all right one let them go
two million it's food it's the food for
the reptile like that's what I'm saying
it's like you don't want to poison it's
like it's free food you know but it
takes money to transport two million
rats maybe we don't transport them maybe
we just take the reptiles and put them
in the New York City that's a good idea
and they just have a snake infestation
that's tight I like that I'm down drop
them in Australia while the snakes are
off Africa oh yeah you know you know
that's how they [__] up all the uh
ecosystems around the world yeah so like
in Hawaii they introduced uh Mongoose
thinking that it'll help the rat problem
out oh but what they [__] up on was
the Mongoose or nocturnal and then the
rats are like so that they they're up at
different times of the day they're
trading shifts yeah I've always wondered
why there's so many of them just like
they they're invasive yeah I heard the
whole like wild hog problem started with
just four pigs oh wow in Hawaii or just
here here they're like there's four pigs
and then they're like well we I forgot
what it was but they're like we can't
afford them so we'll just let them go
and they'll probably just die they
didn't know they were gonna like breed
with the wild hogs and they all became
wild and that's how we got like this
giant infestation dang it's crazy it's
like it's weird like it depends on the
pet you know like when you uh some pets
are okay to see them die and Slaughter
and then some animals it's inhumane to
see them die in Slaughter like who picks
the pet okay what's the difference
between a pig
and a dog right one's cute it's whatever
the white lady likes more yeah and she's
like spiders no we're gonna [__] call
the [__] exterminator we're gonna
fumigate this house but then it is a
cute little mouse um the hog ones on
YouTube I can sit there for hours you
know when they catch all the hogs again
hog traps and then you watch Charlotte's
Web and if a pig dies like it's the end
of the world
what's a hog trap oh my God I mean I
know what the [__] it is by definition
but like what yeah what does it look
it's a big gate that they have like it's
like a big circle gate and then they
have like these automatic feeders where
the Hogs come and they get used to like
oh there's always food here every day so
then the groups get bigger and bigger
and bigger and one day when it's like
when they're all eating
the gates just go boom and it closes
then you see that see that you see the
human nature kick in when you're
scrambling for your life they like hit
running each other yeah they go for
dessert berserk because they're really
smart they get careful at first like the
first time they put the Trap up the
first pig to go is super like reluctant
you see that [__] yeah and then the
other pigs the other Hogs don't even
follow they're like hey is it cool is it
cool is it chill that's why they got to
keep doing it for so long right there
yeah
it's a long time hey but what a way to
get a bunch of free pigs right hey but
rat traps hella easy you guys seen rat
trap videos
I've seen the water bucket ones and
stuff yeah it's a water bucket they'll
put like a uh like a bucket and then
they'll have like uh they'll put a rod
across it that the rat would have to
cross the rod to get the food but the
rod spins like a lumberjack log and the
rat Falls the next one Falls and they
just never learn it's like mxc and then
the bucket's just full of 100 rats and
they're just dead we used to have a big
rat problem his Wipeout yeah it's white
bumps dude Ninja Warrior yeah the rat
traps that were like all the sticky ones
the sticky paper oh yeah and then in the
morning you wake up there's like all
these rats just stuck to it or at night
like um when we first started doing we
were doing the rat traps with the cheese
right and you would hear smack smack and
then and then my parents were like oh
but then like you wake up and then
there's a smashed rat with gut sometimes
and she's like I don't want to do it
that way so then they started getting
the sticky stuff but the sticky one I
think only when the rats are small
because we had it problems with rats the
big ones that just run right through it
the small ones were like
everything sticks to it oh [__] oh oh
man
I don't know I never got grossed out of
rats though but I did have a pet rat
I didn't know they could be a pet until
someone brought one for show and tell
and then she was just like holding the
rat and I was like that's so [__]
dope and then so I used to have a
hamster and I'm like I don't want a
[__] hamster no I want a rap and then
so we got one and it was just like this
big and it grew to be like this big wow
some of them are kind of cute and
they're just chill yeah
how would you [__] annihilate 2
million rats in New York City flight
thrower that's I mean I already told you
my business plan is collect them go to
reptile businesses and just be like yo
but they won't oh you wish you wouldn't
give it to them you're not selling it
but they probably sell for snakes they
freeze it sell it you wouldn't be able
to sell it in a market where they know
there's a million rats loose well you
spread them out over like look for all
the reptile reptile places like spread
them out you know because you because
they're buying the rats yeah they're
buying have you seen a frozen radius
it's nasty it's crazy Frozen rats yeah
you go to reptile my kid's all about it
but mine's fresh and it's [__] um
it's it's cage-free yeah organic you
know what I mean like mine is fresh it
was cage-free no no [__] GMO that
shit's just and it's local it's New York
raised local
nothing but the best yeah and then what
you're getting right now is you're
getting these Lab Rats you're getting
these rats that are in cages like it's
unethical I catch them from the wild
yeah they live good happy lives eating
cheese pizza
[__] hot dogs and [__] falafels yeah
they're eating bagels this is Slurpees
it's just bringing like a hundred
thousand cats and just let them loose in
in New York yeah you have a cat problem
yeah now we got a camera but people love
cats when they walk them down the street
they don't nobody does that with rats
and then after the cats do its job then
we bring in what like dogs 50 000
coyotes
there's tons of coyotes well they went
after that
probably Lions 30 bears
and then what then what back to humans I
don't know [__] put there you go
problem solved pen Hunters 10 Hunters
these numbers are hey but when you go to
Hawaii though and they got all those
like uh Jungle Cats that's just cool
that's what I'm saying what's a jungle
cat yeah they just have a bunch of like
wild cats but they're all like they're
not all [__] up like city cats you
know the city cats got like patches
missing yeah what are the size though
no they're like City cats have access to
drugs jungle cats look like pretty house
cats dude I don't know how they do it
but their fur is all pristine and
they're wild yeah they get loose they're
just pet cats that got loose but they
just live in the [__] jungles and
[__] really yeah in Hawaii huh I'm
saying if a cat is something that a lot
of people walk down the street oh cats
take out the phones like King [__] and
they are natural Predators rats it makes
more sense that's true they're not
really they don't really like bite
through your drywall or like leave [__]
all over the place so just keep the area
nice when I was in Morocco there's a
shitload of cats around and somebody
said that's why there are a lot of cats
because the rats to take care of any
other pets but I don't know if that's
true this it makes sense people don't
people hella run away from cats yeah you
know what I mean but that's I mean
naturally though that's how cats evolve
with humans is when
um you know they just visit they just
live on the farm taking care of all the
rats there's a lot of cats at Disneyland
if you guys know that oh really Disney
cats I've never seen a cat Disney have
you inside Disneyland to catch the rats
to catch all the rats they have a paid
they have an Instagram page like the
cats at Disneyland wow I didn't know
that I rarely see cats in Disneyland I
assume a lot of California Adventure
dude just chilling bro I had a rap
problem I was living in Glendora because
we're close to them no in your brand new
house yeah because what happened was a
lot of the rats come out from the
mountains so I had this whole section
remember like during covid like
um people got like freezers and [__] and
like like you stock up on all kinds of
supplies so I had all these supplies in
the corner of my garage because oh [__]
like you only could have like two two
steaks per family like all that like
rationing stuff so I had stuffed in the
corner and I didn't realize oh [__] rats
like food so but it's like canned food
though you know so you're like oh this
is good but then I think they all those
they can still smell it and then when I
was moving and as I as I was moving
stuff around I would see like the back
of my toilet paper all nibbled through I
had three like REI camping chairs oh
they ate through some of the mesh and
The netting like they just if they go
through something they don't like find
the smartest way they'll just they can
just chew through everything they'll
just choose that's like those crazy
ancient torch techniques and stuff where
they put like strap on that end up in
your stomach and then they like burn one
in so the rat has to they'll just go
right through the uh Fast and Furious
right there
[Music]
flame that [__] was and they heat it up
yeah
they're um I don't know if they still
have this thing but I remember there was
this service that you could pay for and
um if you pay this amount of money it
was supposed to be a prank thing but I
think they stopped doing it you could
pay money a guy will send
to the address of your choice a box with
like hundreds of roaches in it what and
then when the person opens it the
roaches just all come out
Ryan it's like illegal now but like it
was a gray area thing where it's like a
war with someone for that can you
imagine that [__] though you just have a
roach infestation no I'm good dude we're
catching hands for that bro that's
[__] up dude they should just do that
with rats just package them up oh God
gotcha who eats roaches like is it like
iguanas and [__] Chinese yep Chinese
people to the house
[Music]